bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre la reforma educativa
que comenzó a finales de 2015 en perú y
que hoy deja decenas de universidades
cerradas por falta de calidad como
argumenta el gobierno nos acompaña
osvaldo cigarras rojas titular de la
superintendencia nacional de educación
superior universitaria de perú gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
le pregunto cuántas universidades han
sido cerradas y cuál es el principal
motivo para cancelar sus licencias
de 100 buenos días en primer lugar de
144 universidades que existían han
quedado en el camino 50 universidades
por no cumplir con las condiciones
básicas de calidad exigidas en el modelo
del licenciamiento es una potestad de la
superintendencia de analizar y conducir
este proceso para poder sincerar las
condiciones básicas de calidad son 50
universidades que han quedado en el
camino lamentablemente no nos satisface
pero creo que es una obligación para el
mejoramiento de la calidad de la
educación superior en el país ahora como
se explica este número de universidades
cerradas y como fueron avaladas entonces
para su funcionamiento inicial
bueno el año 2015 al crearse a través de
la ley universitaria las unidades las
superintendencias nacionales de
educación universitaria
cuya función fundamental es que conducir
el proceso de licenciamiento para la
verificación de condiciones básicas
mínimas de calidad que debería existir
para la autorización por ley está esta
matriz de condiciones básicas se
aplicaba tanto a universidades nuevas
como a universidades existentes y eso es
lo que originó que su aplicación a
través de un procedimiento muy estricto
y muy este académico y técnico se pudo
digamos sincerar a las universidades que
no cumplían con estas condiciones ahora
cuántos estudiantes se ven afectados por
estar en estas universidades que ahora
están cerradas y qué va a pasar con
ellos
en las 50 universidades más o menos
contaban con doscientos treinta y tantos
mil alumnos 232.000 para ser más exactos
de esos doscientos treinta y dos mil
dado que estas universidades que eran de
negadas nos vendían sus actividades
académicas sino a través de un proceso
que se denomina un proceso de cierre
ordenado en la cual de ellos deben
mantener sus actividades académicas en
estas universidades se han mantenido
alrededor del 60 por ciento de los
estudiantes de estas universidades
alrededor de unos 30 a 35 mil alumnos
que lograron trasladarse a otras
instituciones universitarias por
convenios que estas universidades
delegadas hacían con universidades
licenciados o en su defecto cuando ellos
voluntariamente expontáneamente ellos
fueron hacia otras universidades
además alrededor de 15 a 18 mil alumnos
ya cumplieron con su proceso de s de
educativo
y concurrieron sus carreras en esas
universidades hay un grupo de unos 70 80
mil alumnos que por razones de la
pandemia no hemos podido tener un
registro exacto de ellos cuál es su
destino calculamos que algunas día están
matriculadas en nuestras universidades
otros han desistido o están esperando
que esta situación se normalice por el
continuar sus estudios ahora señor
segarra muy brevemente ya para finalizar
hay intereses detrás de la creación de
estas universidades de baja calidad
no he podido escuchar con mucha
interferencia y le pregunto y brevemente
por favor la respuesta hay intereses
detrás de la creación de estas
universidades de baja calidad
no le escucho no lo escuché hay mucha
interferencia bueno el señor se agarra
por tiempo ya no tengo que despedir
disculpe gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 en este segmento
de entrevista de cinco minutos con era
osvaldo señora rojas titular de la
superintendencia nacional de educación
superior universitaria de perú
muchísimas gracias también ustedes por
siempre acompañarnos aquí en france 24
[Música]